first what does it mean to represent
something I think I know but I'm asking
what I should know and second is it does
to represent something is that different
than to mean something first of all the
big question you ask the bigger question
must then I've said the answer the
second point is that representing is a
component of meaning but it's not
sufficient okay
however once we get representing we're a
long way to get to having me
and what does render done representing
is when one configuration of matter is
about another configuration of matters
so here's a configuration of matter okay
and you generally will interpret it as
about another configuration of matter or
an acoustical disturbance you know the
letter of the alphabet Y and various
configurations of matter that realized
that letter of the alphabet okay but of
course if it's a tree whose branches
have been knocked off by lightning and
which is just sitting there burned out
by the side of the road it doesn't
represent even though it's a
configuration of matter the letter y I'm
not sure that moving from representing
defining representing in terms of being
a ballot there's telling me anything
well I can't weekend the the whole
problem is that we can't cash
the aboutness representation into a
purely physical relation between
configurations of matter now it's dawn
that Dan and Terry want to say and and
the demand that we do so represents a
fundamental mistake about the nature of
meaning and the program of understanding
human thought and speech right so that
okay so and how what is the daylight
between representing and meaning
so this could be in orbits right this
could be in orbit it's it can represent
the movement of a planet around
something it doesn't mean the movement
of a planet around something right its
iconic it's it's like it in some sense
it's got some homomorphisms with what I
want to provide we don't say that that
has meaning but when I use the word I
describe these words to describe it to
you then you'll say that's meaning it's
a special subset of representing in some
context some communicative yes oh and
one of the things the problem with the
term meaning is that we of course
brought it out of language and we
sometimes want to apply it to a domain
that's bigger than language and I think
we get in trouble when we try to do that
but I point to something you know I can
refer to it with my pointing but it
doesn't mean it and I want to be clear
that one of the problems when we expand
out the concept of meaning gets us into
trouble and and I think we want to back
away from it and all we use it in this
special sense of what we're talking
about something that has sort of
linguistic or symbolic kind of features
to it so I but I'm just trying to say
just beware of them what was generally
defined oh absolutely yes right so what
does cat mean I guess what does cat or a
fish or table mean I mean since since
you know you're talking about meaning as
if you had an implicit theory of what
meaning is and now I'd like again I
guess I'd like to know there's enough so
I have a good Network so ways you know
yeah but let's let's let's pick one so
that we can visit well what is that you
know when you know the word can't sighs
well first of all you got a reference
it'll go with it um do you need one oh
yeah absolutely
yep you have to have at least a relative
reference that is the classic notion of
a semantic Network can't occupies
identifies a position in a semantic
network
which you've got animals you've got dogs
hookah chairs it's a position there and
it has to refer to but by itself it does
not refer to anything in the world if I
mean something by virtue of being in a
network with other meanings
[Music]
there could be an organism that had
exactly one Khans leaf won't and that
this would be the true because there
would be a state in that organisms
nervous system but mantas no it's like
independently of everything else that
just intrinsically meant it now for us
this is preposterous preposterous we
can't make sense of that at all we think
the only way you could believe that
snow-white
is by a baleen what's always and knowing
what white is and having the the
conceptual and perceptual equipment to
to partition the world into the parts
that were smell the parts that were
white from the parts that works no in
the parts that work but and having it
you can't know only one thing about you
and having an apparatus that allows you
to do composition so no I'm not no not a
freezing that may be insane but meanings
the only hope of a theory of meaning is
going to be one which looks at what we
might call shorthand network properties
now Fodor has a name for this shoe
because it meaning hose
and he's written a whole book attacking
us yep don't bother leaving that book
well go ahead go ahead and read it and
find out how wrong we all are but so
there are people that disagree with this
I'm still I guess I'm still under
unsatisfied an undergraduate since all
you've said is it's in a network now and
tell me more about what that network
actually contains is it just for
instance a listing of features it was I
mean well that's okay so maybe you can
develop the concept a bit more okay and
that physical configuration of matter
there are certain physical relations to
a lot of other configurations of matter
that are outside of your head and that
particular set of physical
configurations of matters what
constitutes them the meaning of who
thanks to the physical configurations
have to do this well how else is gonna
network which is a certain scent like
lexical role and it's related to other
objects in my in my meeting space so
when I say cat is like horse this can
make sense to me there's a correlational
aspect presumably to demeaning sure but
it doesn't the one core Brett what's
correlators well we're using all these
exits let's you know you have to
actually figure out what kind of
experiment shows me what's in your what
let's take madam actually that's not
like falling off a truck that means I
have to make commitments to a
representational set of primitive area
die so I have to adopt a particular
position on let's say in this case
lexical semantics not compositional
semantics so I actually do the sort of
thing and I'm completely unmoved by its
in a network that's not an account
that's not even descriptively adequate
so first of all I think my whole view on
this is that we're talking awake to a
higher level
and even as a neuroscientist I think
that you know we're in big trouble
because we've got all of these unknowns
and it's such a huge monster and for me
I basically have given that story up
until I can tell the lone story I don't
even want to go there for all of those
reasons even though I spent a good part
of my career trying to do that I think
we're so confused about it for exactly
the reasons you're asking we you know
and this is the question about
verification about whether verification
works whether correlation is enough
whether being a network is enough
obviously there's some kinds of
referential relationships like pointing
that don't need to have any Network
features student but yet they provide
this feature one of the questions really
is is there a kind of internal pointing
behavior that's going on in the network
it's the network not just some sort of
abstraction but is it actually a kind of
internal pointing behavior I actually
think it is kind of vector kind of
system now I don't think I can cash that
out in the way you would like nor that I
would like I've been wanting to do it
for you know a generation but I think we
can work our way up to it and I think
that's the problem
there's and I think so too AM I'm
relentlessly optimistic about this today
but I think the D that's staying in the
extremely abstract level discussions
just unhelpful yeah I think remember we
only were locked in it yeah we didn't we
didn't bring up this overly abstract
Network stuff right you knew what we
were talking about meaning and we were
using meaning as a different from a band
I healed
the network is that's what it is being
in a network but only that one response
to the request that we saying why do we
think meaning is more than
representation
you